notre page spécialité et dernier volet
notre voyage dans la vallée du loir ce
soir on revient sur le festival de
montoir dédié aux danses et musiques
traditionnelles
cette année encore le rendez-vous
connaît un vif succès il est aussi une
tribune d'expression pour certains
peuples jean pierre aubry créé quark
riche mois dans les coulisses du
festival c'est là que les artistes qui
se produit chaque soir affichent leur
identité culturelle derrière les masques
et sous les costumes
il y a des garçons et des filles qui ont
amené avec eux leur propre histoire
celle de leurs peuples en asie en
amérique du sud ou en afrique souvent
douloureuses comme celle de ses
bourreaux et des réfugiés en belgique et
qui ont créé leur propre ensemble pour
transmettre leur message
si j'avais la paix au burundi gens que
pas rester ici parce que j'ai envie dos
parce que l'on payé d'être ensemble avec
ma famille mahrez magie
voilà c'est des choses quand même qu'il
investissait en europe et je commence à
penser pourquoi je quitte mon pays et
jour ses entrées d'eau galérait
en europe on était super qu'on serait
monté traqué
l'histoire de ces artistes tibétains est
identique réfugié en inde
le groupe a été créé par le dalaï lama
pour préserver et promouvoir la
tradition unique de leur pays que la
chine cherche à faire disparaître les
artistes du kalimantan est sur l'île de
bornéo
c'est la culture destaillac qui est
menacé comme leur territoire d'ailleurs
par la déforestation pour tous le
festival de montoir offre une tribune à
travers des conférences mais aussi des
ateliers comme celui ci où les artistes
transmettent leurs coutumes au public
expliquant leur lieu celle des minorités
menacées d'extinction le festival de
montoir qui compte cette année 250
bénévoles devient ainsi une formidable
tribune où peuvent s'exprimer
les peuples des cinq continents
alors me dit bonsoir tu fais partie des
jeunes bénévoles de ce festival
mais comment tu es arrivé ici justement
je suis arrivé par le biais d'un
prospectus qui s'est baladé dans une
fête de la musique de trop des jeunes
qui montent pas sur le prospectus et
j'ai pris contact avec ces jeunes et
j'essaie de voir ce que c'était ce monde
et
quelques minutes ici ça m'a suffit de
revenir encore cette année c'est
superman tôt alors le président du
festival en fête a donné une grosse
responsabilité parce qu'au bout de deux
ans de bénévolat
il était à donner la responsabilité
d'organiser en fait tout le staff jeunes
c'est ça bah j'ai constitué une petite
équipe de jeunes que j'ai ramené tout au
long de l'année et mon but là c'était de
créer les plannings créé tout ce qui
était horaire est équipé en gros aux
coordinateurs et j'essaye au mieux de
réussir et pour l'instant ça marche je
prenais sûr ça marche alors comment ça
se passe avec les anciens parce qu'il ya
les anciens qui sont là depuis 10 20 30
40 33 mais non ça se passe il ya
toujours cette limite avec eux mais ça
se passe très bien dans l'ensemble si on
essaie d'aller d'aller vers eux
d'apprendre à les connaître tout ça
généralement cette limite s'efface un
petit peu il ya toujours des anciens qui
restent dans leur optique qui veulent
pas trop de jeunes et de plus en plus
cette frontière et commence à s'effacer
l heure est à donner aussi une
responsabilité président c'est à dire de
d'organiser un petit peu cet espace qui
est quand même nouveau l'avant scène
mais aussi à le tenir certains stands
c'est ça non en fait où il place des
jeunes de plus en plus c'est ça donc là
les jeunes travaillent à la buvette aux
glaces au service est de plus en plus là
on a doublé de jeunes par rapport à
l'année dernière
alors il ya autre chose également qu'il
faut souligner c'est vous demande de
faire des propositions alors vous avez
proposé l'avant-scène donc avant le
festival lui-même
vous avez d'autres idées vous allez
apporter pour l'instant dans ma tête là
j'ai pas trop d'idée je pense qu'il
faudrait créer quelque chose encore plus
constructifs avec des jeunes des
vraiment des enfants comme festival à
l'instant ça s'est déroulé ça c'est
encore très bien passé cette année mais
pourquoi pas d'autres choses avec les
jeunes aussi et alors avec les groupes
qui viennent
il ya des contacts de réels qui se crée
ils sont jeunes aussi oui ben ari dès le
soir après leur spectacle on essaie
d'aller les voir d'aller d'apprendre de
leur culture de leurs langages c c à
chaque fois c'est des bons souvenirs
ça reste à vis de la écoute bon courage
mais dit ainsi à toute équivoque si
molle donc en ce qui nous concerne la
semaine spéciale sur la vallée du loir
se termine ce soir donc merci d'être
fidèle à france 3